well after that surprise visit from the
first lady there were
more visitors congratulating juliana
uttabay on her recognition
as victoria saha reports from the
governor to one closest to her
it's been an emotional morning here at
kermit our booker elementary as he
celebrated juliana uttabay
now we got a chance to speak with her
parents who she credits
as her backbone throughout her career in
education
a first for nevada as juliana ortube was
recognized as a national teacher of the
year for 2021
and the first latina finalist for the
award since 1992.
i could not have been more proud of mr
tobay for representing her students
our state and educators throughout the
nation
is a special education teacher it's an
emotional day it's a happy day
these tears are tears of joy those
emotions were shared by otome's family
as they beamed with pride about their
daughter's new title
she has been working so hard for so many
years
and every single project is very serious
for her her parents say urtabey's love
for wanting to make a difference started
even before her teaching career in
first grade there was a
blind girl a blind student and
she helped her to do everything that
need for wanting to help has given
urtube the national spotlight
i take the time to understand who they
are their journeys their struggles their
stories
and uplift them in a way that brings
their strengths forward
making a difference one student at a
time
urtube says as we celebrate her she will
continue celebrating all the teachers
across the country victoria saha 8 news
now